good morning I'm just delighted to join
Dean Miller and welcoming you class of
2016 to Yale College I want to welcome
also the relatives and friends who have
accompanied you here and especially your
parents as a father of four college
graduates I know how proud your parents
are you parents are of your children's
achievements and how hopeful you are for
their future and how many concerns both
large and small that you have at this
moment so let me try to reassure you
your children are going to love it here
and I expect that you are going to enjoy
your association with Yale whether you
are a returning graduate or one of the
vast majority of parents who never set
foot in new haven until your children
started to think about where to go to
college you may take comfort in learning
that surveys have shown that Yale
parents are the most satisfied in the
Ivy League
so welcome to the Yale family we're
pleased to have your children with us
and we will do our best to provide them
with abundant opportunities to learn and
thrive in the years ahead aunty you
class of 2016 welcome I suspect that you
have many different reasons for being
here you may have chosen to attend Yale
College because you heard it was a place
that attracted unusually talented and
interesting students perhaps you were
impressed by the depth and breadth of
our 2000 course offerings you may have
been drawn to the idea of residential
colleges communities that are microcosms
of the student body and that inspire
lifelong loyalties you may have learned
about the diverse array of undergraduate
organizations here devoted to politics
debate journalism and community service
organizations that will give you a
chance to develop your skills as leaders
and its collaborators you may have been
drawn by Yale's superlative
undergraduate arts organizations from
Chamber Orchestra's too dramatic
societies from dance ensembles to
acapella singing groups you may have
been recruited to one of our 35 varsity
athletic teams with their outstanding
coaches and facilities you may have
learned about our commitment to
sustainability and been interested to
join one of our environmental groups or
to work on the Yale farm or you may have
been excited by the extraordinary array
of international experiences open to you
as students in yo college all of these
are good reasons to find Yale a school
worthy of four years of your time but I
thought that I might focus this morning
on an aspect of Yale that you might not
have considered and that is the special
advantages of your having chosen to
attend a college that is situated within
one of the world's great research
universities this distinction means
first
that the faculty who will teach you here
are leading scholars in their respective
fields among the world's very best and
second that you will have access here to
virtually unmatched library and museum
resources consider first the
extraordinary collections that are
available to you in the yale university
art gallery PL center for british art
and the yale peabody museum of natural
history dozens of your professors in
literature history the history of art
anthropology geology ecology and
evolutionary biology will make use of
these museum resources in the courses
you take and perhaps some of you will
join with other students in actually
curating your own museum exhibit last
spring for undergraduates collaborated
with curators and conservators at the
Yale Center for British art to study the
materials and techniques used in the
creation of early English wood panel
paintings they created an exhibit that
was on display here at the center from
April through July a year earlier Yale
students collaborated with other
students at the University of Maryland
to create an exhibit on african-american
art drawn from Yale's collections that
was shown both here at our art gallery
and on the University of Maryland campus
now even if you don't engage quite as
deeply as to curate an exhibit I would
nonetheless urge you to visit our
museums you may discover there a love of
art or a love of nature that enriches
your entire life our libraries are an
endless source of discovery for students
who wish to engage in archival research
you'll find materials there that allow
you to undertake projects that go far
beyond what might be possible elsewhere
some years ago one undergraduate
discovered the uncataloged papers of a
deceased professor and in them he found
that a faculty organization called the
Yale library project had provided cover
for a very important World War two
intelligence mission
just this week I learned from a high
school student who was working in the
archives of the vine aki library about
his discovery of the methods used by
late 19th century railroads to finance
their sale of farmland to settlers in
the northern plains of the United States
it turns out that the railroads
strategies for helping landowners remain
on their farms during periods of
financial hardship were much more
effective than our current efforts to
protect homeowners from foreclosure
during the current recession now
consider next some examples of the
astonishingly creative and original work
of the faculty who will be teaching your
courses earlier this year professor John
Lewis gaddis professor of history won
the Pulitzer Prize for his brilliant
biography of George Kennan the diplomat
and architect of the United States cold
war strategy recently a group of
scientists led by Rick Prum a professor
of ecology and evolutionary biology was
able to deduce from fossils the colors
of feathers on a dinosaur geologist jane
wang wang has demonstrated that carbon
can be captured from the atmosphere and
sequestered not in gaseous or liquid
form beneath the earth's surface but in
solid form by catalyzing a reaction to
transform subsurface rocks into calcium
and magnesium carbonate this is one of
several technologies that Yale
scientists are pursuing in the hope of
finding solutions to the problem of
global warming historian Timothy Snyder
has shown in his recent book blood lands
the ideological and practical
connections between the nazi
extermination of the Jews and other East
Europeans and the Soviet extermination
of the same populations in her path
breaking work the ornament of the mind
professor Maria Rosa menak all
demonstrated that the Middle Ages in
Spain were
at a time of darkness and superstition
but a period in which Muslim Christian
and Jewish literature philosophy and
architecture flourished and profoundly
influenced one another in the Western
Desert of Egypt archaeologist john
darnell has unearthed a lost city a site
of a massive bread making industry more
than 3,500 years ago and finally to
complete this list of amazing research
projects your Dean Mary Miller has just
given you a glimpse a glimpse of her
immense knowledge of Mesoamerican
history art and culture in her own work
of rediscovery fee has employed infrared
photography to produce enhanced
high-resolution images of the Mayan
murals at Bonampak and she's used these
images as a platform for seminal
reinterpretations of Mayan art
architecture and civilization what's
remarkable about studying here in Yale
College is that you will have direct
access to these scholars and many others
distinguished as they are in research
they are also committed to teaching you
you will take their courses participate
in their seminars have the opportunity
to work as their research assistants or
do independent research under their
supervision most of the projects I just
described involved students in some
capacity but here are a few more in
which the role of students is front and
center consider for example professor
Scott struggles course in which
undergraduates travel over spring break
to a tropical rain forest to gather
endophytes these are microorganisms that
are found in abundance on plants the
students then return to Yale where the
work where they work for the balance of
the spring semester and throughout the
summer to characterize the organisms
they have found and discovered their
properties on recent rain forest
expedition students have found several
organisms that effectively degrade
plastic one in particular is capable of
breaking down polyurethane in the
absence of oxygen holding great promise
for practical use in the biodegradation
of buried trash or perhaps you'll be
intrigued by the opportunity to hunt for
exoplanets bodies that orbit around
stars other than our own Sun you could
do this under the supervision of
professor Deborah Fisher and her
colleagues in astronomy professor Fisher
helped to launch an online citizen
science project called planet hunters
which engages 40,000 web users in the
search for exoplanets using data
gathered from a NASA space mission three
yale college students collaborated on
the first published paper from the
planet hunter project announcing the
discovery of two previously unidentified
exoplanets two other undergraduates are
co-authors on a paper describing another
discovery that will soon be published
one of the students involved in the
first paper is now working on a team
that has developed a new device capable
of doubling the precision of the Keck
telescope making the world's largest
telescope even more powerful and finally
if you'd like to combine an interest in
the performing arts with serious study
you might consider participation in the
Yale baroque opera project conceived by
the eminent musicologist Ellen rose and
who's made major contributions to our
understanding of early music the baroque
opera project introduces students to the
historical aesthetic and performance
issues related to 19th century related
to top the Italian opera of the
seventeenth and early 18th century they
do this in their coursework and then
mount to full-scale productions each
year these examples illustrate how you
might benefit from participating in the
work of a university committed to path
breaking research I encourage you in the
strongest possible terms to take full
advantage of the people and resources
here don't be shy yells faculty
libraries and museums are here for you
if you want to get engaged with the
amazing research activities that go on
here don't hesitate to ask a professor a
librarian or a music or museum curator
they'll welcome your interest and let me
go one step farther if you want to get
the most from your Yale education you
have to be adventurous do not content
yourself with a familiar path as you
choose your courses try something
different an expository or creative
writing class statistics instead of more
calculus or new language even as you
pursue further study of one you already
know sign up for courses and projects
that will challenge you you may never
again have so much opportunity to
explore new ideas to test out new
directions to pursue different routes to
discovering your true passion stretch
yourself and I offer the same advice in
connection with the activities outside
the classrooms and museums and libraries
seek out the unfamiliar if the friends
you make here are exclusively those who
come from backgrounds just like your own
and it went to high schools just like
your own you will have forfeited half
the value of a Yale education you come
from 54 nations from a wide range of
racial religious and socioeconomic
backgrounds each of your residential
colleges contains within itself that
rich diversity seek out friends with
different histories and different
interests you will find that you learn
the most from people the least like you
in the same way as you choose your
extracurricular activities try to move
beyond the familiar try at least one
activity that is brand new to you
volunteer for community service and
begin to understand how what you have
learned here might be of value to others
work or study abroad in one of our many
summer programs and see the world from a
different perspective and so women and
men of the class of 2016 you may have
come here for many different reasons
but now that you're about to begin your
four-year journey of discovery take note
that you've come to one of the world's
great research universities then this
presents you with very special
opportunities learn from your teachers
the joy of participating in the
advancement of human understanding of
nature and culture draw upon the
abundant resources of our libraries
museums and laboratories stretch
yourselves to your limits intellectually
and interpersonally your effort will be
richly rewarded thank you